All right.
Let's do this one last time.
My name is Conan Denise O'Brien.
When I was 15 years old I was bitten
by a radioactive party
clown at my quinceañera.
You probably know the rest.
With no talent, comes no responsibility.
Dad, how does that help me?
It doesn't.
Too late old man.
That feral clown gave me powers
beyond my wildest dreams,
which made me very popular in high school.
(locker banging sound)
And popular with the ladies.
I even met my first love.
(soft music)
(rock music)
Now I could've used my
powers to fight crime,
battle evil
and rescue innocent people.
Asshole.
But instead I opted for cheap laughs
and light celebrity chat.
You're afraid of heights?
Yes, it's true, it's true.
Fascinating!
Mm-hmm.
(crowd laughing)
I even met my best friend, Andy.
I'm so sick of your voice!
Yup, the Conan empire's alive and well.
I have a hit podcast, a cereal,
a line of toys, a sex column
in South West airlines magazine,
an erectile dysfunction medication
and was recently named the face
of skin cancer awareness in Malaysia.
And now, I've returned
to San Diego Comic-Con®
for the fifth time.
I'm like the cool high
school student who graduates
and comes back to hang out the next year.
Everybody loves that guy.
Hey, are you Amy Adams?
No.
I am Comic-Con®!
And Comic-Con® is me!
(police siren plays in the background)
Step down from the mailbox, Ms.Adams.
(car horn screeches)
(upbeat jazz music)